françois roux sur le mardi 1er mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
à l'occasion du salon de l'agriculture
nous vous proposons cette semaine une
série de reportages sur les yvelinois
présents à cet événement aujourd'hui le
portrait de catherine colère bouchard à
coignières elles participent à ce rendez
vous porte de versailles pour la
première fois et nous faisons également
découvrir l'attelage équestres aux haras
des bréviaires il existe une école
d'attelage et de nombreux stages sont
proposés pendant les vacances
l'occasion de découvrir cette discipline
qui s'adresse à tous et nous devions
recevoir ce soir les représentants de
l'association juris tribune de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines pour évoquer avec eux la
reconstitution du procès alexandra lange
qui se déroulera le 11 mars en raison
d'un dysfonctionnement au sein de la
structure
ils ne pourront pas être présents ce
soir veuillez nous excuser de ce
problème qui reste bien sûr indépendant
notre volonté est depuis 3h ce matin
l'ensemble des salariés du site xp au
logistique sont en grève à trappes de
manifeste une nouvelle organisation de
la logistique avec un groupe de grande
distribution annoncée par la direction
la semaine dernière pour l'occasion un
intersyndicale a été créée hier
il regroupe force ouvrière la cgt la
cftc la cgc et la hesse ap
cette nouvelle organisation
représenterait une perte de 50 % du
volume traité par xp au logistique
les syndicats de moins donc l'arrêt
immédiat du projet selon lé délégué
syndical de la cgt environ 130 postes
pourraient être supprimés
écoutez ces précisions recueillies au
micro de camille lambert fort chez moi
au moins deux volets - dits fictifs
derrière 600 d'entre eux notre crainte
aujourd'hui si ces suppressions de
postes et là on est là aujourd'hui pour
montrer à
la direction qu'on est déterminé qu on
va tout faire pour garder pour
sauvegarder l'emploi de nos collègues sa
peau des risques mais ça peut dire est
comme ça peut être des semaines que
c'est aujourd'hui on a des réponses
satisfaisantes on reprendra le travail
de mam mais pour l'instant on n'a
toujours pas de réponse ou le déterminée
jusqu'au bout et nous avons bien sûr
recontacter xp ou logistique dans un
communiqué un porte parole affirme que
je cite ledit client un grand groupe de
distribution et a fait part de sa
volonté de faire évoluer l'organisation
logistique de son activité multi formats
en ile-de-france cette évolution inscrit
la collaboration de longue date entre ce
client et xp logistique dans la durée
les niveaux d'activité qui sont confiées
ex de logistique seront maintenus à des
niveaux proches de ceux actuellement
traités par ses équipes le groupe
poursuit actuellement ses échanges avec
son client pour travailler ensemble la
définition de la future organisation de
l'activité
il a invité ses collaborateurs en grève
à reprendre le dialogue
et chaque année l'assemblée nationale
rend public sur son site internet
l'utilisation faite par les
parlementaires de leurs réserves
financières ces fameuses 130000 euros
que chaque élu est libre d'utiliser pour
soutenir associations et entreprises de
son choix ainsi on apprend que
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines a reçu vingt mille euros de
valérie pécresse lorsqu'elle était
encore député et 20000 euros
supplémentaires de benoît hamon
quant à henri guaino député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines il a versé
15 mille euros à l'association rêves qui
aide les enfants hospitalisés
on pourrait aussi citer les 8000 euros
de françois de mazières députés sur la
circonscription de versailles pour le
club de handball de la commune ou encore
les 1000 euros de david bowie de david
douillet pardon pour le bowling club de
plaisir
david douillet député de la 12e
circonscription tous les chiffres sont
bien sûr à retrouver sur le site
internet de l'assemblée nationale
et à présent nous recevons sur ce
plateau williams elle pour une autre
chronique williams cette semaine vous
allez nous parler de l'eau qui voit tout
à fait florane alors l'opievoy qu'est ce
que ces copies voix c'est un bailleur
social
d'ailleurs ces deux second plus gros
bailleur social de france l'opievoy en
quelques chiffres c'est plus de 50 mille
logements étalé sur sept départements
d'île de france
ils sont présents sur 191 commune loges
plus de 180 mille personnes d'ailleurs
dans l'est
yvelines il totalise plus de dix sept
mille cinq cents logements l'opievoy ça
se décompose en deux organismes le
principal c'est loupé à shopi voix
l'office public d'habitat
interdépartemental qui a été créée en
1920 par le président de la république
de l'époque
donc c'est une structure assez ancien le
second c'est l'association logo ted qui
a été repris en 1999 et qui propose un
accompagnement social et une réinsertion
par l'habitat temporaire un royaume quoi
vous êtes intéressé au bailleur social
aujourd'hui
alors c'est plutôt simple en réalité
l'opievoy aujourd'hui est victime de la
loi pour l'accès au logement est un
humanisme rénover plus communément
appelée loi allure concrètement cela
veut dire qu'au 31 décembre 2016
les offices hlm publics devront être
rattachés à une collectivité locale
unique alors première solution c'est la
région ile-de-france qui aurait pu la
reprendre mais valérie pécresse y
étaient opposés
ça a été voté la semaine dernière la
reprise ne se fera pas l'annoncé a été
faite le sort de la pivoine ne dépend
pas de la région il dépend il est de la
responsabilité de l'état
c'est l'état qui a pris ses
responsabilités en rédigeant une oie
allure qui a tenté à un moment de forcer
la main de la région et de l'obliger
quasiment à reprendre
l'eau qui voit le rôle de la région
c'est d'impulser une politique d'aidé
par exemple les franciliens qui le
souhaitent et qui le peuvent à devenir
propriétaires d'impulser une véritable
politique du logement en cofinançant du
parc locatif social
l'ambition de la région n'est pas de
devenir de constituer un patrimoine
immobilier
alors si j'ai bien tout compris c'est
surtout une difficulté d'accord entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales tout à fait florane ça
c'est l'une des raisons l'autre raison
c'est surtout la dette de l'opi voit une
dette qui s'élève à plus d'un milliard
d'euros et surtout une dette dont
personne ne veut dans lequel sa
réinscription anciens justement on est
au coeur du problème
aujourd'hui puisque le conseil régional
d'île de france ne reprendra pas
l'opievoy le bailleur ne peut plus
continuer à exister sous cette forme
c'est à dire qu'il sera certainement 10
et chaque département devra se
débrouiller seul de son côté soit en
trouvant un bailleur privé soit en
passant par un office habitable
départementale départementale pardon
comme c'est le cas pour le val d'oise
avec valophis habitat problèmes dans les
yvelines et dans l'essonne il n'en
existe pas alors les présidents des deux
conseils départementaux avaient envisagé
la création d'une structure il ya
quelques mois nous avons contacté
l'opievoy ainsi que son président pierre
bédier qui pour le moment refusé toute
demande d'interview sur le sujet nous
avons par contre rencontré un
administrateur et représentants des
locataires de l'opi voit dans les
yvelines qui nous a fait part de ses
craintes quant au devenir de la
structure de la structure à l'échelle
d'agrandir grands groupements comme
pierre bédier en train de faire avec les
eaux seine avec le gps au pourquoi pas
se doter d'un outil 80 mille locataires
c'est je ne comprends pas d'un côté en
favorise des regroupements
intercommunaux favorise des grosses
structures les hypers structure et une
hyper structures comme pouvait l'être
sopi voit on la cassant la case pourquoi
parce que les les conseils
départementaux veulent leur fils veulent
petit pré carré volvestre vol gérer de
la gestion locative du logement du
logement social
nous les locataires au sein de l'appui
voir nous informe pas donc ce que je
souhaite moi c'est qu'on soit informé
qu'on soit associée au processus
décisionnel et pas et pas comme c'est
factuellement on aime on nous associe
strictement rien donc ce dont on se rend
compte c'est que les locataires du moins
ce que demande ce représentant c'est de
pouvoir donner leur avis dans les
décisions qui vont être prises et
surtout d'être tenu au courant de ces
décisions
les locataires qui seront les premiers
impactés par les changements
nous sommes d'ailleurs en allant
rencontrer quelques-uns n'ont su pied
parce que ça va bien être pris à un
moment où one drop ou séparés où il y
aura bien quelque chose si c'est un
certain qu'on va devenir encore pierre
ça promet moi j'ai eu aucune
appréhension par rapport à ça parce que
de toutes les manières que que ce soit
l'eau pierrois ou anneau d'ailleurs ça
sera toujours la même chose des
bâtiments seront toujours là les
locataires aussi on aura toujours notre
travail à faire a effectué que ce soit
moi gardien mais mes collègues chargés
de clientèle responsables de sites et
autres cadres n'ont pas l'air vraiment
acquérir williams un nom flore année
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous a confié
cette dernière
personne qui est gardien à saint cyr
l'école c'est que les locataires auront
toujours un toit sur leur tête et que
les balises les bâtiments seront
toujours là simplement aujourd'hui
aucune solution n'est encore proposé par
les dirigeants de l'hôpital qui je le
rappelle ne pourra pas continuer à
exister sous cette forme
c'est un dossier donc assez important
qu'il va falloir suivre d'ailleurs une
première réunion avec les dirigeants et
prévue la semaine prochaine
les locataires auront donc normalement
plus de certitudes quant à l'avenir de
la structure
le 8 mars prochain merci beaucoup et
william pour toute information c'est
rené qui était très intéressante et je
ne vous dis pas ça parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la journée mondiale du compliment
et passons maintenant au salon de
l'agriculture la viande n'est pas qu'une
affaire de testostérone malgré les
chiffres qui démontrent que le secteur
de la boucherie est essentiellement
composée d'hommes de plus en plus de
femmes aujourd'hui se dirigent vers ce
secteur qui ne connaît pas la crise
à coignières catherine gaud l'air et
bouchère pour une grande marque de
viande
elle a été sélectionnée pour représenter
et mettre en valeur en valeur pardon
l'enseigne au salon de l'agriculture
c'est le premier reportage de notre
série que nous avons réalisé cette
semaine au salon de l'agriculture
william el est fanny bourdillon
kenny tu peut trancher la poitrine ce
sera fait comme ça à 25 ans seulement
catherine et responsable des ventes et
dirige déjà sa propre équipe pour une
grande enseigne de viande la boucherie
c'est 10 % de femmes pour 90 % d'hommes
un milieu dans lequel catherine a su
s'imposer malgré tout à la base ça reste
un métier d'homme mais on voit quand
même de plus en plus de 5 de bouchehr
qui accède à cette profession c'est vrai
que c'est difficile c'est assez rude
on travaille dans le froid les horaires
sont assez il faut se lever tôt le matin
c'est à 3 heures du matin faut être sûr
dans le bio j'ai un mental de rock
d'acier donc c'est ce qui m'a apporté
beaucoup de choses aussi pour le
management d'une équipe d'hommes en fait
et avec ceci madame vous avez la promo
du rosbif aujourd'hui à tempérament
récompensés puisque quatrime est
aujourd'hui représentante de la marque
au salon de l'agriculture
nous l'avons rencontrée en séance de
démonstration voilà je m'apprête à faire
un filet mignon tout ça donc la base un
filet mignon et petites tomates cerises
pour la décoration
j'ai de la crépine pour l'entourer
percier et le fromage de chèvre une
représentation d'une journée où
catherine mettra en valeur avec fierté
sa profession en préparant des pièces de
viande sous les yeux des visiteurs
très impressionnant faut vraiment être
réveillé pour être sur le qui vive
il ya beaucoup de gens qui posent des
questions qui demandent ce qu'on fait ça
représente tout notre travail ça
représente la france en général c'est en
valorisant ce métier à travers justement
une personnalité féminine
on va justement développer ce métier on
diminue le côté boucher avec le ventre
rond là mon stage et on passe sur un
métier vraiment dynamique avec des
jeunes femmes qui trouve vraiment leur
voix dans le métier pollution et la mise
en avant de la femme dans un milieu où
elle est peu représentée est une des
valeurs de cette enseigne est un secteur
qui ne connaît pas la crise dans les
deux prochaines années ce sont 4500
postes qui sont à pourvoir dans le
secteur et demain deuxième épisode de
notre série de reportages à spécialement
consacrée au salon de l'agriculture et
sera question de la ferme de viltain à
jouy en josas et porte de versailles il
hier il n'y avait pas que le salon de
l'agriculture le fromage et les produits
laitiers étaient aussi à l'honneur avec
leur propre salon l'événement
incontournable c'était le concours de la
lyre d'or qui récompense le savoir-faire
dans la création d'un plateau de
fromages
l'épreuve a duré une heure et demie le
critère principal composer un plateau de
fromages uniquement de couleur blanche
et orange
parmi les douze candidats qui ont tenté
de décrocher la précieuse récompense
arnaud dufour illinois il habite à ou
dont il est reparti les mains vides mais
il nous explique les enjeux de ce
concours
l'année dernière j'étais spectateur en
me disant que j'aimerais bien y
participer
et puis deux puis j'ai ouvert mon
magasin je suis dire cette année on va
le tenter puisque c'est tous les deux
ans il ya effectivement une
reconnaissance du métier ou si on fait
un beau plateau c'est l'activité noble
de notre activité on n'est pas que
vendeur de fromage
tous les jours j'ai des clients qui vous
demande un plateau pour les fêtes pour
noël pour un repas et faut être
imaginatif faut être créatif c'est aussi
de montrer notre savoir faire nous
allons maintenant parler cheval nous en
trouvons sens de l'agriculture mais
également au haras des bréviaires le
haras national des bréviaires qui est
surtout connue pour ses activités de
reproduction et qu'il propose également
différentes activités hippiques
depuis deux ans une école d'attelage a
été créé au haras et pendant les
vacances de nombreux stages sont
proposés
je vous propose de découvrir cette
discipline qui s'adresse à tous regardez
ce ne sont pas des cavaliers et nous
décoché mais des meneurs depuis un peu
plus d'une journée
ces stages est révolu sous l'oeil
attentif de guillaume singer responsable
des cures d'attelage au haras des
bréviaires en attelage on est tout de
suite au gain voilà il ne faut pas
attendre d'avoir une bonne assiette de
ceux de se tenir sur sur sur ces deux
jeux trier là on s'assoit dans un siège
on a les guides on pilote francheval
tout de suite mais avant de s'essayer au
galop le meneur doit préparer son
attelage on met au cheval un harnais
composé d'une sellette d'un collier d'un
monte les deux brides la pièce
principale ce sont les guides de long
grain qui vont permettre de diriger la
monture
ça c'est la pollution de base ensuite
position de base aide et on met toujours
le petit doigt avec les autres parce que
là comme ça ça c'est une réflexe de
cavaliers jérôme apprend à ses
stagiaires comment conduire les chevaux
avec les deux guides un peu
d'entraînement pour savoir mener au
carré puis ne reste qu'à attacher la
voiture et se rendre dans la carrière
aujourd'hui les chevaux vont travailler
les trois allures ne pas le trot et le
galop un programme pas très différent
d'une séance de dressage habituel des
exigences physiques moins lourde que
pour les cavaliers traditionnel experts
ou novices ils découvrent de nouvelles
sensations
on découvre des sensations de contact
avec le cheval que l'on n'a pas vraiment
lorsqu'on fait de la balade avec des
personnes en calèche quoi il ya un
contact avec le cheval permanent dans le
travail hatley ça permet aussi de voir
d'autres horizons d'aller se promener en
promenade en forêt voilà quoi et tout en
continuant à travailler à avoir une
d'aidé optique de travail sur le sur son
chemin après quatre jours les stagiaires
sont autonomes et maîtrise seule leur
voiture et leur cheval alors si vous
vous sentez l'âme d'un meneur l'attelage
et peut être fait pour vous et si pour
les vacances d'hiver vous appreniez à
créer votre propre jeu vidéo c'est ce
que propose la ville de guyancourt pour
les jeunes de 11 à 17 ans et des du
logiciel connu ils sont une douzaine à
programmer leur propre univers si que
leurs personnages codé avec audio de
quoi laisser place à l'imagination un
reportage signé camille lambert
on est parti vous ouvrez un nouveau
monde donc vous sauvegardez votre monde
et vous ouvrez un nouveau monde parce
que il faut mieux repartir à plat
créer son propre monde un rêve devenu
réalité pour ces douze jeunes guyancourt
toit depuis lundi 29 février ils se
familiarisent avec le logiciel connu le
but programmer leurs jeux vidéo de a à z
les objectifs c'est découvrir la
programmation développer leur imaginaire
pouvoir aussi développeur et puis après
faciliter les échanges entre jeunes au
lieu d'être devant seul devant leur
ordinateur là ils peuvent échanger
modelé un terrain construire un
personnage ou imaginer des labyrinthes
autant de possibilités facile à réaliser
grâce à une interface ludique
tout est beaucoup plus simplifié au
niveau du mapping et des programmes en
fait du coup c'est vraiment plus
accessible aux plus jeunes
ça nous apprend à un peu a programmé à
comprendre le jeu vidéo c'est bien parce
que si on fait ce métier plus tard par
mois on sera déjà school enfin comment
on pourra faire les apprentis concepteur
de jeux vidéo ont encore la journée de
jeudi pour se former
le logiciel est gratuit ils pourront
donc repartir chez eux avec leur univers
et continuer à laisser libre cours à
leur imagination
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis rester avec nous tout
de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
nicolas attiré levitt et ses invités
pour le 7-8 société thème du débat
un monde agricole en crise je vous dis à
demain pour un nouveau journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée